fue uno de los líderes africanos más
populares de los últimos 40 años thomas
sankara nació en 1949 en el norte de
burkina faso entonces conocido como alto
volta se formó en una academia militar
de madagascar en 1984 tras un golpe de
estado dirigido por place company fue
nombrado presidente de burkina faso fue
un carismático presidente izquierdista y
feminista
hay que dar un trabajo a todas las
mujeres toda mujer debe poder ganarse la
vida con dignidad y honestidad
sankara se oponía a que los países
pobres pagaran sus deudas a las naciones
occidentales
promovió vastas campañas de vacunación y
debates
[Música]
contra hermanos y sólo si somos capaces
de confrontar constantemente nuestras
ideas podremos ver lo que quieren las
masas
and estimadas
debemos tratar de ajustarnos a los
conceptos clásicos y académicos
impuestos por occidente cruza un click
del método de fusión de agua
a veces era un líder autoritario la
población era controlada por los
llamados comités de defensa de la
revolución pero tras sólo tres años como
presidente fue asesinado place campaña y
tomó entonces el poder fue derrocado
casi tres décadas después en 2014 y huyó
a costa de marfil